they are still counting votes this
morning in a series of primary elections
that could determine who controls
Congress next year eight states held
their primaries yesterday the most
important race was in California which
has 12 percent of all US House seats
Democrats are trying to flip seven seats
where voters elected Republicans in 2016
but also preferred Hillary Clinton for
president that O'Keefe is here now to
sort through all the top results good
morning and welcome good morning guys
California uses an open primary system
where the top two vote getters move on
regardless of party Democrats filled a
large field the candidates might
overwhelm voters creating a space for
Republicans to win both spots but those
fears seem to have been avoided
America's future is still being defined
by California's present in his victory
speech Tuesday night Democrat Gavin
Newsom the frontrunner for governor
highlighted the pivotal role California
will play this November Democrats need
to gain 23 seats to take back control of
the House of Representatives with
results still coming in it looks like
Democrats made it on the ballot in all
of California's potential swing
districts that will help the party as it
looks for pickup opportunities
nationwide in other races across the
country it was a good night for female
candidates New Mexico Democrats
nominated congresswoman Michelle Lujan
Grisham for governor a win would make
her the state's second straight Latina
executive but she faces a tough fight
against GOP Congressman Steve Pearce in
South Dakota Republicans hoped to make
congresswoman Kristi Noem the state's
first female governor we have a bold
vision for the state and some reforms
that need to happen pitting her against
Democratic state senator Billie Sutton
but in Alabama for term congresswoman
Martha Roby was challenged in the
Republican primary and forced into a
runoff election Roby was the first GOP
member of Congress to take back her
endorsement of then candidate Donald
Trump how are you following the release
of that now infamous Access Hollywood
tape more signs of how well women are
doing some could make even more history
in New Mexico Democrat Deb Hale ined is
seeking to become the first Native
American woman elected to Congress
and in California young Kim a Republican
hopes to become the first Korean
American woman ever elected to Congress
know quite a quite a number of results
there how are they number shaping up to
you
we at CBS projected toss up still you
need to eighteen to win right now we say
Democrats would get to nineteen so they
need everything they can find thanks